Welcome everyone to my EmacsCons presentation where we're going to look at
lists the demo app from 1978 but done in modern elisp. Then we're going to look at
getting inferior lists working, my dear commonlisp. And then we're going to use the
commonlisp interface manager, the open source child, the commonlisp interface
manager, mid-clim from inferior lists in superior lists, which is the opposite
order that I initially thought we were going to do things in but this is how it's
kind of turned out. So it's this article I thought from 1978 was interesting to
us today, programming in an interactive environment, the list experience,
explaining what all these list programmers were doing to people unfamiliar
with list programming. List systems have been used for highly interactive
programming for more than a decade. This was from 1978 and we're just going to go
and almost verbatim port the demo application for a list out of 1978 interlisp
and into EmacsLisp. And we're going to do it without ORG mode because I think
everyone is finding out how great ORG mode is already. For inferior lists I
thought instead of ORG mode we'll theme it around Slime mode and then it turned
out most of this presentation happens in EmacsLisp because this is an EmacsLisp
conference. But I found out that there's IL mode which is pretty similar to
Slime mode. But in our hearts we can imagine that this is an Emacs
example, home around Slime mode, superior list interactive interaction mode for
Emacs, instead of ORG mode. Though you know I do secretly use ORG mode as well,
not very secretly. But that means we're kind of improvising, improvising or
presentation mode. So we have this big buffer of Elisp and let's just, this is me,
not Sandwall, AdventRest. Let's make a keyboard macro, go get the S expression
wherever the cursor is, move it to the next S expression, paste it in here and
the keyboard macro, all right. And what was basically happening? So the demo
application in this case is a scheduling application. And so you can imagine
improvising a calendar like this if you weren't existingly using an ORG mode
integrated calendar. So you know just have a list and maybe each list is of
sublists where the first element, the car of the sublist I guess is a sensible
sounding date format like SAT, DEX, SEVEN. This is clearly the first day of
EmacsCon. And after that a list of basically from and two times and then a
quick written description of of the of whatever event was at that time. So
similar to what we were seeing recently as me recording this in our
structured interpretation of computer programs, study group, you have all these
little methods. So hours of a time is actually just car of the time, minutes of
the time, cat or time. And so we all know these kind of little basically turning
car and cat or which we do use into descriptive names like from and to. You can see
how this lines up with the appointments. So for reproducibly building Emacs
described event, I guess from would be 1625. Let's just grab that and let's
really use those because we're interactive programming, right? So we have this
quoted form and then let's do from of that great and let's do minutes. So from
1625 1645 reproducibly building Emacs. So when I do from to that I get 1625 and I
do minutes to 1625. I get 25. And a description of this number in octal hex and
hexadec. What was up next? Okay. Getting next day from date. And so what was
it? Saturdays, December 27. So what happens? So this function, ACIS was part of
sandwell's personal exploration of Adams using symbols with with with
property lists with with an attached property list every symbol. And so you can
kind of see how this works. I get whatever was keyed by the symbol next week day
out of the day symbol. So I guess we would do so if we had sat December 6. I guess
we get sad. Oh, it destructors that itself somehow get next week day. Sorry, next
day. Set December 6th. But of course these weren't defined yet. So what if we set
get set next week day. And it's gonna be something, right? Then if we next day set
December 6th. Sunday December 7th. Yeah, so that kind of makes sense in an intuitive
way. And you can see Cond is being used. So you're not a list person. Cond evaluates
a condition. If the condition returns non-nell executes the code attached to that
condition. It evaluates each of these conditions in terms and turn and then stops when one returns
non-nell as you might expect as a list programmer. Now let's keep marching along. Okay, but so
we have to populate this and this this was an interesting one. As you can see, I'm this
was my attempt. Let days, month, you, wed, so forth. Then I used CL loop from Emax less, you
know, four day and days for next and quarter days set for next week day. And this I thought
was surprisingly deep was that this programmer, Sandwell thought, are basically constantly
trying to break new ground and they lose interest very quickly when that's not what they're
doing. And it was making the point that we breaking new ground involves solving a problem
exactly once. And so you kind of should do it in the most expedient way possible to solve
it kind of for the first time. And after that, it's not breaking new ground anymore. And
so I thought that was a kind of fun point from from Sandwell's paper that we could kind
of chew on. Do something similar for months and month lengths. But as we can see, if I get
up nerd days, I think I think that characters in 1978 characters and symbols in 1978 were
more precious, which is why Sandwell was writing in this abbreviated way. So we might write
more verbosely these days. We get 28, but it is in fact a leap year. So let's just set
that to be 29. Now it's fine. Then I guess if we do, we're we doing next next day. Sure.
Next day, I don't know what day it was. Let's assume it was Sunday, February 28. Some kind
of table crept in there, but we can deal with it. Let's just set. Get sun next week day month.
So once we've we've solved it once, we should be fine, right? Okay, I think I have to speed
up a bit. There we go. Monday, February 29. And then what if we next day, Tuesday marks first.
Okay, it basically seems to be working. And I'd argue it's actually fun that we kind of had
to do that. Then just imagining, you're kind of functioning with other people day begins
at 900 ends at 1700, so kind of a nine to five imagining, though, though, perhaps shorter
is more appropriate, but let's not quibble about that. What was happening next in this
app? All is in. Oh, yeah. So get me the free slots in from start time list of appointments
remembering characters, I guess, were more precious is my my theory. And then entire. So if I go
holes in and then from 900 to where I've written nine space, zero, zero, and what's what are
my appointments? So I have a list of appointments that need to have start times and finish time.
So let's go 12, 59 to 13, one. The description, I guess, can be test. And then let's finish that
at 1700, like we were kind of thought. Oops. Some of these are meant to be arguments.
Okay, there we go. And so the available times between nine and five, if there's one appointment
from 12, 59 to one, one are from nine to 12, 59 and from one past one to five, which is
kind of what we were expecting. And so our appointment at this kind of coming along. Then
we have common holes. Kind of works in a sensible way. Do we have what are some common
holes from two lists of appointments, I guess, common holes? Yes, let's have one person
have an appointment from nine to 10. That's going to be their only appointment. And let's
have another person have an appointment from nine 30 to 10 30. Oh, we didn't do before
time yet. This is the order, sandwall, implemented things in there. Okay, there. So the common holes
are from nine 30 to 10. Let's actually be overlapping time. I'll record this if some kind
of problem has kept into my things. And then what to be the first start by doing, Emacs
Conf, Track 1, and Emacs Conf, Track 2, and we'll do it on Saturday, December 7th. I'm in
time and I'm being prompted, of course, Emacs Conf, Track 1, Emacs Conf, Track 2, the date
that we grabbed, let's say we want five minutes. And as always, I'm forgetting to quote things.
And so my opportunities for common times between Emacs Conf, Track 1, Emacs Conf, Track
2 on the first day of the conference, Saturday, December 7th for five minutes. I have an opportunity
between 9, 29, 40, 11, 40, and 1, 13, 10, 13, 25, 13, 45, 13, 55, and 16, 15, to 16, 25. So I
think that's all working. And it was done with almost exactly the same code.
Except for my loopy, populating, symbol, P list, bits earlier. In Interlisp in 1978, as Emacs
Lisp in 2024. And I thought that was pretty interesting that you could do that. I think set, set,
get, was put prop was the biggest difference in 1978 Interlisp and modern Emacs Lisp. And obviously
modern Emacs Lisp has common Lisp loop in it kind of. It's another big difference. How are we doing
for time? 17 minutes? Great. Because now let's get a bit closer to what my talk title is promised
of we're going to use common Lisp from Emacs Lisp. And we're going to use common Lisp
Interface Manager, the open source implementation of common Lisp Interface Manager from inferior
Lisp from Emacs Lisp. And what we just went over in Sandwall's paper. This was the starting point.
And Sandwall says, well, if you just kind of jammed these ideas using Lisp, you just kind of made
hour a synonym for car and minute a synonym for catter and so forth. You can then make a whole bunch
of improvements. Can we actually get a glimpse of the, no, I didn't really write this. Yeah, so you
can see, I basically just ported out of the interlisp code in the text of this paper. Yeah, you see
from Lambda of appointment, car appointment. And that's defined to, I guess, interlisp in 1978,
used define queue, whereas we used defon in ELSP. But I'd encourage you to explore that
yourselves. But the extension that I wanted to develop today is since common Lisp Interface
Manager is just Lisp. And inferior Lisp is just Lisp. And Emacs Lisp is just Lisp. And interlisp
in 1978 is just Lisp. We could kind of use them all together in a kind of funky way. But a complaint
that you often hear or a statement of confusion that you often hear as a Lisp person, people from
other languages often can't, can't kind of figure out how to get started with Lisp. So I'm
just gonna try and do everything here and now. This is the second piece of my three pieces. So let's
just get inferior Lisp and make claim happening. And so we normally use Slime Superior Lisp
Interaction Mode for Emacs, which we could get from, from the Emacs, from Emacs's package
manager. So if I go package Lisp packages. And then we wait for however fast my network is.
We're going to see how long it's been since I updated something. Yeah, but you see it's in Malper, right?
It's got to be somewhere here. Yeah, all right. So there's one Slime available and I can do one
possibly more recent one available in the Malapot package repositories. I don't know about you,
but I can sympathize with people who feel confused by this because I think if you look online,
if you did a kind of search engine result, it doesn't customize these like I customize them.
So let's just do this customize variable package archives. And you can see here I've inst,
GNU, non GNU, and Malper, it's Malper, not Malper stable. So you can set.
So that's how I do that. So we're just kind of totally get an inferior Lisp working.
And then like we saw before, it's my occur buffer still open. No, occur. Slime.
So we could install and execute that. I cloned Slime since commonless people might use Slime and Swank.
Like McTlem does outside of Emax. I think we can secretly see I've got it here already in my.emax.esline.
But you could install it like that. So the hotkey is I and then execute to execute the install. I
realize you all already know this. But many of you might not yet be commonless programmers. And you
can use both superior and inferior Lisp. Instead of package archives in Emax, in inferior Lisp,
and with great controversy, we often use quick Lisp. People sometimes complain quick Lisp
releases get out of date quite quickly. But there was one recently. So they're pretty in date.
And so this should be a, yeah. So basically you download quick Lisp.Lisp, you check it's
Sha 256 Sum. So I guess in U over here, I press D,
screw tape downloads quick Lisp.Lisp, great. We open a shell, realize that this is this is just
riveting for all of our experts there. Sha 256 downloads.
Quick Lisp.Lisp. Your Sha 256 might be different lines. Somebody please tell me during the actual
conference the right Emax idiom to do this. I guess it will be tools decrypt something.
But then once you have quick Lisp, let's go back to our shell.
I'm on open BSD or a BSD. So I type package ad ECL to get embeddable commonless.
However, I think I already have it. And then let's start embeddable common Lisp.
Quick Lisp inserts itself already.
But just loading that quick Lisp.Lisp file kind of would get you here anyway.
Now let's QL, quick load, midclim. I'm actually following my plan.
Midclim is kind of like Emax in that it handles all sorts of graph or stuff like if you have GTK
Emax, you know, it can do really a lot of stuff. And that's the reason why compiling and loading
the midclim package takes a while. And I do use my old computer laptop, my old computer
challenge laptop all the time. So when you do this, your computer will be substantially faster
or you will be feeling smug about how slow you're running your computer. And so there's no problem.
Next we're going to start swank, which is the Lisp part of Emax's slime mode.
So if I remember we looked at this before, so in my dot Emax dot D, and then there should be
slime, start swank. Let's just grab that and load it. You don't have to type sharp sign P,
the string work as well as a path name, but it's kind of fun to do so. Now slime connect,
you installed slime earlier, default values. Oh, the reason we had to do this and not use slime,
start slime normally was that Clim, Commonless Interface Manager, McClim implementation of the
Commonless Interface Manager spec also uses swank and McClim really wants to be in the driver's seat.
So so we can have our Emax connect to the McClim that to the swank that McClim was already running.
So in package, Clim user, I don't know if this is an Emax less idiom,
soon normally have user packages to absorb user code just for kind of fooling around.
And then let's just use, use, uh, Clim at all. And so Clim does lots of things around presentations,
but one thing it does is automatically to a large extent generate, um, graphical user interfaces.
And so there's a lot to it that's not about graphics, uh, kind of kind of richer interfaces,
than NC Commonless character streams. Um, but let's let's use it to grab a graphical
pop up that returns a value. So we have this accepting values tool. T is just choose whatever you
think the default stream is. We're going to want our own window T as well. Um, so just a keyword
argument. After that, we can just write things like accept string. And I'm just doing this in
for people only listening. I've just done this in my ECL slime REPL, enter a string,
all to enter. I think it's the shortcut to return that. As you can see, it's first return with
food bar bags. And it had second and third returns string being the type presentation type
that it got. And T, I think to indicate that it exited successfully. Um, we can also do
expression might be more interesting. There are a whole bunch of these, uh,
Climbs, examples folder is pretty good. And the documentation, everybody's documentation,
my Climbs documentation, you know, uh, list works and franzes documentation. I'll tell you about,
about the different, um, default presentation types you can accept. Um,
and they're, they're pretty intuitive. And they're, they're kind of very list compatible.
Everything kind of is we could accept an expression. Um, food bar bez.
Return food bar bez 123 because that's what I wrote. Um, and now the kind of piece to
resist all of putting those things together. Um, just run over to our scratch buffer.
Oh, or our IL thing, right? That's what we're actually doing. So now, I think we're going to do
now by all our meta colon. I think it's going to be slime.
Eval save because it'll eval asynchronously. There's a question of how to get the value out of the
asynchronous slime evaluation. And so an obvious way is to, is to yank it. Um,
I'm looking forward to learning from kicking Vegas. He finally makes it stick in my brain. How to,
options other than just starting to write a command in the mini buffer and then mashing,
mashing tab and looking at what the likely sounding results are. That's what I will be learning
this conference. Um, if anything, slime eval saves and then what was happening over here?
Accepting values T own window T except expression. Uh, kind of confusingly.
Slime eval save takes a string. Um, but it works really well. I argue. I think it's about to work really well.
Okay, this is great. So you can see I've, I've used, oh, please enter an expression.
So we're doing an expression. And so that's right. Like three, four over two,
five over six. That's an expression, right?
And now I've yanked it. I should have really been in scratch because I just want to dump.
Sorry, scratch. Dump whatever that did. Oh, yeah. And see, it kind of simplified that while it was reading it.
So, um, running in elus slime eval save accepting values T own window T except expression.
And, and I got the three returns all the way from McClim to inferior less to elus three to five over
six. Second return was a presentation type of expression return successfully T. Yes, that's
pretty cool. Um, how out of time are we? Oh, we did this in basically half an hour.
Maybe we could stop and assume there will be a bit under half an hour of interactive discussion.
And when I also watch this and also receive suggestions, there will be additions and changes to
make I think. But can we quickly defon, defon, accept date? Let's not take any arguments.
Let's do this. Accept date.
Saturday, December seven.
Oh, it doesn't return it. But it gets pretty close to returning it. I guess it yanks it. I would have to
call. I'm going to say it's slime sink at which point it will resolve the slime eval async.
And then I could get the first value out of my coloring pop, right?
Is coloring pop what I want? You know, you tell me in the in the interactive feedback,
which should be happening in lamb to them. Well, I'll record another draft of this later after
getting some feedback or worse to worse. This is just what you'll hear. Hopefully we have
some questions and constructive comments. All right, see everybody later. Thank you so much for being
here. Please do drop in to my live show. If you're so inclined on Wednesdays where you're not busy
with cool EMAX conferences. The list be go for climate. Thank you to everyone who helped.
Thank you to Sasha for really getting me into this conference and kind of getting me going and
submitting this pre-recorded talk. See you everybody later.